i'm so nervous
is everyone ready maybe
[Music]
um so my name is gabby and i'm a
kindergarten teacher
when did you know that you were bisexual
um
i've kind of always known since i was
like 14 or 15 but i actually didn't come
out until
earlier this year now more people are
gonna know i guess
surprise
we're gonna bring people out now okay
i'm ready
should i point or just like just like a
giant ipad
okay i'm so nervous
so many people
hello
[Music]
20 people didn't sound like a lot but
now it feels like a lot of people
is everyone ready maybe
[Music]
i was eliminated on a left swipe
immediately
[Music]
i got swipe left on it would have been
cool i'm also a
teacher so
[Music]
bye
okay like half and half and cool
hello everybody seeing a lot of cuffed
jeans
though
[Music]
go
bye friends
[Music]
hello i'm gabby hi
i'm liv live yeah like live your life i
love that i'm gabby
catherine louie how are you doing today
nervous but excited i was honestly weird
to shake someone's hand
i feel like i haven't done that in
forever i love your eyes
thank you your soup's cute thank you
thank you
thank you thanks i really like your hair
did you do it
thank you yeah i did i actually went to
dry bar this morning because
i don't know my girlfriend why are you
here today
why am i here i'm i'm single me too
okay great that's good that's a good
start it's been a while
since i dated um because there was a
pandemic
makes sense so i'm looking to get back
out there cool
i'm trying to just treat this like a
regular first date yeah which i'd be
just as nervous
except we're in a weird like white void
yeah i mean this is how on my first date
goes
i mean you're carrying yourself well
thank you i i hide my anxiety very
well i need to learn from you and your
feet barely touch the ground
just like don't touch the ground how
tall are you i'm five feet
nice me too i feel like a child honestly
in this chair
i'm a professional dancer that's amazing
yeah
that's why i'm always moving i can't
help it i love your energy
i think i love you thank you so sweet
i'm a kindergarten teacher
you know i actually knew that because
i've seen you on tick-tock you have
oh my god does anybody hear that sound
is it the oh my gosh it is the banana i
feel like you have like a teacher energy
in like the best way
thank you the kids they don't cry every
day so i feel like i'm doing something
right
it's kind of out of my comfort zone
since i'm really introverted and get
social anxiety but i figured
gotta push yourself outside of your
comfort zone social anxiety this is the
perfect place to be with all these
people
exactly you said you're living in san
diego yeah
i just moved there in october oh cool
yeah well if you need a friend i'm there
so have you tried dating apps before
yeah i'm currently on a couple
nice okay i'm gonna think of a random
question
what's your favorite color my favorite
color uh
maybe purple purple i see that
uh what's your favorite movie um bring
it on
probably stop i love perfect that's my
favorite movie no it's not
i've probably seen it like 50 times in
my life i could recite the entire thing
from beginning
oh my gosh i'm sexy i'm cute finding
dory has a place in my heart because
dory's i'm
like my spirit animal she's cute and
dorky and
fun that's exactly why i love her even
though she's an animated fish
but if we were like in a mosh pit would
you partake in it no no
i'm too small i'd be afraid for sure for
sure and totally
i understand that i teach as well but oh
no way
i teach jewish studies to kids
me too oh my gosh what do you like to
do um when you're not teaching um
sleep and
drink alcohol on the weekends
yeah when i'm not teaching of course
obviously all right nice to meet you
too bye nice to meet you nice to meet
you too
very tall nice to meet you too
too tall that was everybody oh my
goodness
that was so fast it's like sorority
recruitment
i feel like from here to here i was
pretty put together
and then my legs were where all my
anxiety went because they were just
going like this the whole time
she was adorable super sweet and
friendly i'm still getting used to like
talking to people again they're probably
like lulls in the conversation but
otherwise it was nice
i don't really remember much i just
remembered the scene why
uh and that was it
do you really anyone in mind everyone
was so nice
um but there is one person that i think
i want to talk to again
what happens now she's just gonna come
back
hello again nice to hello again yes nice
to see you again
so i really liked talking to you earlier
so
i was i thought you could come back and
we could talk more i would love that
yeah i'm really glad you picked me
because i want to get to know you too
thank you
i would ask for your phone number yeah
in the other room
my phone's over there i can go get it
inside of it
yeah should i get mine too yeah okay
i'm so basic i have a clear phone case
isn't that like a buy thing
yeah cuff jeans clear phone case i'm a
stereotype all around my clothing
category no you're fine how can people
know
so i guess you're by then too yeah and
i can't remember did you say you were
vaccinated i am i got my moderna
nice i got a sizer oh nice so cool
i know some of the coffee places i could
take you too cool
[Laughter]
i just found one really near my house
that's very good